hello everybody hope that you are good
today's video is going to be about
Bitcoin day trading you know how this
goes the ual thing yesterday's video was
a bit different because we talked about
altcoins more specifically artificial
intelligence altcoins and from a swing
trading or investing point of view okay
CU we were talking about Nvidia how
Nvidia has outperformed even Bitcoin so
far this year pushed the S&P to new
highs last week was in video conference
and they talked a l about artificial
intelligence again so there is there was
an opportunity to really invest into
artificial intelligence tokens in crypto
okay because they were going to follow
that Trend The Narrative of artificial
intelligence so we're going to talk
about Bitcoin in a minute but let me
introduce you because since that video
of yesterday a few things have happened
so we talk about fetch oan the elisium
we talk about few coins but not too many
maybe four or five and if you go and
check them out now check fetch what is
doing
it's going up since yesterday okay going
up ocean well ocean is quite interesting
because I said yesterday to do a a buy a
market price and then to leave a cheeky
buy order at the 4 or 50 May so one buy
order here another one market price and
today went up 30% up check this out so
from this level but it's even going more
40% up I already lock some profits in
this week here I think it was around
155 156 but I went higher after but I
took some profits of that position
because of course if if it goes up 30%
I'm going to take some profit so um that
this went up is not because of me it's
not because of my mention in yesterday's
video it's impossible yesterday I only
talked about very big market cap coins
oan fetch delium I cannot move them it's
impossible okay but today they released
some very good news and it was that fets
an oan and also Singularity token we
didn't talk about yesterday but um it's
just a good project although I prefer to
be honest uh fs and ocean they are
working well that in talks about merging
the three tokens into one token that
will be a huge token with a very high
Market cup um imagine putting some of
the top AI tokens into one single token
it would have a very high market cap and
this in my opinion is not only good for
these projects but also very good for
the rest for example we're talking about
elicium we're talking about pal there
are some tokens that could do very well
but also there is going to be new tokens
that are going to do well uh recently
the the I saw a prel of a tech AI Tech
um in cify I think it was they did well
but of course there are going to be new
tokens of artificial intelligence coming
out now the problem is how to identify
that they actually use artificial
intelligence or not because of course
because the hype of AI some projects
said that they use it but they don't
really use it that much so that's a
different topic but that's going be very
big for artificial intelligence
narrative if it gets confirmed okay and
they're talking that maybe gets
confirmed this week this new so I'm
going to pay attention to that okay now
following again with that go to the
delion chart this is so far what I'm
paying attention to I mentioned it
yesterday but basically following a bit
of P Price action I said that lium tends
to FAL push above the 4 or 50a retrace
to test a support you can see that with
test support one 2 three four five times
that's a very good support test and the
next thing I could do is continuation to
the upsite now this chart I think I'm
using a different chart because I cannot
see the week but in this chart this is
it in fact we almost got that already
okay but I was talking about 057 57
cents and we already got to 55 but who
knows maybe we come again to the 4 or 50
m and we see that final push High okay
that's what I'm paying attention to to
be honest I want to check ER what
happened because I didn't see that we go
actually the high so I think that I
didn't take any profits yet I think my
take profits was higher so I think I'm
still in the in the trade to be honest
now I want to talk about Bitcoin because
this is what this video is about it's
about Bitcoin really day trading and to
be honest there is not much to update
okay I'm going to tell you my thoughts
so this was the first scenario that we
were keeping all on you could see here
that we were doing lower highs and lower
lows all the time you see so of course
that was a down a downtrend and then I
was saying that my first scenario was to
see a change of a trend here after we H
tested the support again and also we had
a week here fill the week and change the
structure okay instead there you can
make a higher low and safe upop because
there was a lot of liquidity to the
upside to be honest and of course you
had here the
450ma that you needed to to Really flip
okay so far it's playing out uh this
retrace came a bit L later but you can
see how I was you know also thinking
about $2,000 retrace which just go here
so hopefully you can forgive me for that
difference there I keep it the same
though but what I'm saying is that I'm
expecting to see some continuation to
the upsite now uh the thing that
concerns me the most is that uh the
retail Trader is probably seeing the
same because they're going to see here
this buf bu bull flag you call it I
think yes and it's this thing here okay
so what the average R Trader is going to
do is probably going to measure this
like here and then say okay we're in a
bull flag and the breakout is going to
be the same and it's going to take us to
77,000 I don't know if they do it like
that I think I think yes if I'm not
wrong but that's the only thing that
concerns me how I going to trade this
well uh I've checked the liquidity we're
want to go to h capital in a moment but
you're going to see how the liquidity is
still to the upside so to me the safest
way to trade this is going to be to open
a new small position here at market
price and then at another order at the
4H hour 50 ma with a bigger size just
because I don't want to miss out in this
move because according to my projection
this is the ret that I was looking for
all right so of course I want to join
here and I want to see if this can have
some continuation to the
upsite sorry and in the worst case that
we
drop I don't really see bit
falling below the 450ma okay that's
going to be my validation my validation
is going to be acceptance below the 4 50
Ma so if we see something like that I
get out of the trade but in the worst
case I think that we could find some
support there okay at
67k so uh that's what I'm thinking DCA
in in here I think is what I'm going to
do so one order here one order here of
course it's not Financial advice I'm
just only sharing with you what I'm
doing okay what I'm planning to do and
to support this Theory I want to take
you to high block capital I want to have
a look at what the liquidity is and we
can learn something together h capital
liquidation levels you guys know the
rule first the liquidation levels then
the heat map I can see the Delta $13
billion worth of long liquidations is
quite a lot but it might not be enough
to see a reversal okay uh we could talk
about reversals about very L reversal
once this hits 25 30
35 billion dollar okay of course take
this amount with a pinch of salt because
it's not real I'm using the max
liquidity setting because that's what
I'm used to so it's of course a lot less
maybe I don't know $400,000 or something
like that but what I'm saying is that
the Delta is not telling me that there
should be a reversal now to the downside
because the amount is not making that
clear okay it's not that high it's high
but it's not that high
so perhaps first they want to take this
all of this liquidity absorve these
liquidations here and then yes they can
talk about reversal okay that's what I'm
thinking but nothing very clear about
this chart today so I'm not going to
take anything into into account now the
liquidation hit map is showing something
a bit more interesting and is that in
the 7 Days time frame we can see a
jellow bar of liquidations at
71,7 and that is telling us that in the
low time frame in the short term the
liquidity is to the upside so
it's very possible that we come to this
area in the next I don't know 24 hours
okay either in this New York session or
maximum tomorrow in New York session
that's what I'm thinking okay so keep an
eye on on this on this level
71,7 shortterm Target possibly yes now
in the one month time frame now things
got a be more complex here because
you're going to see that uh there is a
lot more to talk about here okay I'm
going to take all of this area
you can see that there is really
liquidity to both sides so we have a lot
of liquidity about
74,000 but also below 60,000 all the way
to 54,000 there is call of
liquidity
so how can we
favor one site or the other it's
difficult okay the site is playing with
an advantage that it's simply that we
are closer to it it's a fact uh we're at
70,000 so we are closer to 75,000 and to
60,000 half as close um to this level so
that's going to play an advantage into
considering that 74,000 could come next
instead of 60,000 okay now if you notice
here the liquidity is really above these
highs and that's quite normal okay and
that is telling me that that's not only
going to be liquidations but also stop
losses okay so the liquidity in this
area is really high higher the same as
here I'm not going to lie to you below
60,000 there is also some stop losses
but I guess less because if we already
moved up
7K I'm sure that some Traders have
already Trail their stop loss is higher
maybe to 65k or yeah probably below this
peot here at 67,000 so there is going to
be more stop losses at the highs at 75k
so not sure what's going to happen to be
honest uh have to be careful
but I would risk to say that I'm going
to favor the liquidity to the upsite I'm
going to favor higher prices and that's
why I'm looking as of today for long
positions in Bitcoin with low risk okay
that's what I was talking about opening
a small order here a small size I I
repeat and then in case we see that drop
to I don't know if it wases to 67 66 the
4 50 ma is there you can see in the
chart then a bigger order that if we can
hold it a support and if we lose the
support then of course invalidate I make
a small loss and we try again tomorrow
so that's what I'm looking at for today
okay that's a little update of Bitcoin I
still think that the original projection
to 74,000 it could be still in play and
that's so far what I'm putting my money
on okay so that's pretty much everything
guys thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you
soon
[Music]